dominique trinquent ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès de
l'onu bonsoir général merci d'être avec
nous en direct par téléphone sur rtl
france florence parly qui évoque des
erreurs mais pas de faute
responsables mais pas coupables quelle
est la nuance dans le fond alors avant
de parler de la nuance parlons des faits
le premier fait intéressant qui a été
soulevé que par entendu dans votre
reportage c'est que là la première
contamination au virus se fait en fait
au mois de février dans la méditerranée
or à ce moment là il est probable que
l'équipage et c'est pour ça qu'on parle
d'erreurs d'appréciation le commandement
se référer aux épidémies antérieures
h1n1 en particulier ni vous ni moins au
mois de février le savions exactement ce
que c'était le connard navires us si
tenté que nous le sachions aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs et donc les mesures qui ont
été prises à l'époque ont été prises en
fonction des connaissances que le
commandement avait d'une épidémie de
type grippal
donc effectivement aujourd'hui on dit
qu'il ya eu une erreur d'appréciation
ça veut dire concrètement vêtements vous
dites premier cas en février en
méditerranée il aurait peut-être fallu
suspens de la mission plutôt alors le
porte-avions je vous parlais est pas par
hasard du h1n1 parce qu'ils avaient été
contaminés à l'époque et l'émeute qui
avait été prise avait permis de
sauvegarder l'équipage et de continuer
la mission donc les mêmes mesures ont
été appliquées
mais malheureusement l'épidémie n'avait
rien à voir mais à l'époque au mois de
février il ne le savait pas alors
ensuite et bien sûr il ya les escales la
fameuse escale de de brest 1 qui
arrivait en plus tôt en fin de mission
pour le porte avions et donc les mesures
qui avaient été prises avant laisser à
penser qu'il n'y avait pas de
propagation et là effectivement il ya
une propagation plus importante avec
comme vous le disiez l'évacuation en
particulier d'un marin à copenhague
alors la ministre a également évoqué un
excès de confiance en face encore un
virus
la part du du commandant du charles de
gaulle est ce que ce n'est pas
surprenant tout de même de parler de
d'excès de confiance pour un un
militaire sachant que cette épidémie
elle date quand même voilà d'avant on
avait le retour d'expérience de la chine
tout de même bon elles auront février on
avait pas tellement
souvenez vous c'est arrivé vraiment fin
février début mars
et effectivement à l'époque il ya eu une
appréciation d'ailleurs il n'y a pas on
ne parle pas du commandement du ben du
bateau à on parle du commandement de
façon générale et du service de santé il
faut savoir que le rendement est bien
sûr assisté par des médecins
donc il ya eu une erreur d'appréciation
c'est certain à l'époque sur le porte
avions globalement et donc les mesures
n'ont peut-être pas été prise compte
tenu de la gravité de ceux qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui du coronavirus alors
laquelle la 14ème imposé à bord prenait
fin le 30 mars le sport a repris à bord
il ya même eu un concert organisé pour
remobiliser
l'équipage là aussi selon vous est ce
qu'on peut parler d'erreur de jugement
mais oui mais alors si vous voulez il
faut faire très attention à ce qu'on dit
vous noterez que le l'équipage a été
totalement tester quand il était à
toulon il a été mis en 14 n est
aujourd'hui l'équipage est sorti et
quasiment aucun membre de l'équipage n'a
été vraiment malade je ne sais pas si
vous si moi n'avons pas compte à quel
coronavirus - au mois de février
j'ai une forte grippe mal dans le dos
j'ai pas été testée c'était un
coronavirus qui s'est arrêtée là
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble de l'équipage
1700 personnel de l'équipage il y à un
marin qui a été en réanimation et qui en
est sorti aujourd'hui
donc si vous voulez il faut garder la
mesure des choses et mais il reste
évident que des bateaux ont une
promiscuité est telle qu'il faut se
méfier et que probablement
l'appréciation n'a pas été fait au bon
moment et le bateau a bien fait de
rentrer en tout cas pour pouvoir tester
l'ensemble de l'équipage et rassurer
tout le monde sur le fait que d'abord il
n'y a pas de malades très grave sauf un
le répète et qu'il n'y a eu aucune perte
dans l'équipage
désormais on parle de test systématique
avant de partir en mission c'est une
bonne chose ça a le mérite de clarifier
les situations
oui où il avait raison aujourd'hui on
part de test et encore une fois il ya
trois mois on prévoyait pas ces choses
là
aujourd'hui il y as tests avant de
partir en opération c'est très important
pour plusieurs raisons la première
raison c'est que d'envoyer des gens qui
ne sont pas malades en opération ils ont
besoin de toutes leurs capacités
la deuxième c'est que les pays dans
lesquels les gens vont en opération ne
soit pas contaminée donc il est très
important effectivement de tester et
aujourd'hui les forces qui se prépare
vous savez on des préparations
opérationnelles et dans ses préparations
opérationnelles
il ya une période de quatorze elle et il
ya en plus des tests pour s'assurer
qu'on n'envoie personne malade en
opération merci j'avais un demi train
avant d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france